la france galvanisé par la victoire des
tricolores une france ce enthousiaste en
dehors de tous les clivages l'assemblée
nationale déploient une banderole pour
soutenir les bleus
dans moins d'une heure sur le champ de
mars à paris plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes pour assister à ce
concert unique des trois ténors
pavarotti carreiras domingo diffusé en
mondiovision les départs en vacances
avec ce vendredi classé rouge en ile de
france pourtant la circulation est
fluide aux portes de paris appelle à la
vigilance des conducteurs nouvelle
campagne de prévention coup d'envoi du
tour de france prologue demain à dublin
en irlande
les derniers préparatifs visite de
médical des coureurs festival d'aix en
provence avec don giovanni de mozart un
événement la mise en scène de peter
brook prend le parti d'un spectacle
moderne et joyeux madame monsieur
bonsoir la france ceux touchés par la
grâce du football traverse est elle une
phase d'euphorie une étrange fièvre
disent les sociologues fait d'un
sentiment national joyeux et
multiraciale les centaines de milliers
de supporteurs qui célébrait mercredi
soir au delà de tous les clivages
sociaux
la victoire des tricolores donne la
mesure de cet enthousiasme communicatif
et voilà que maintenant l'assemblée
nationale porte sur sa façade les
couleurs de la france en finale
sébastien guibert à la location
la cérémonie se veut solennel un grand
cri du coeur s'est affiché ce matin sur
un mur de l'assemblée nationale allez
les bleus allez la france
encouragements symbolique à l'heure où
la nation vie pour certains des jours
historiques
elle peut gagner et que quand elle gagne
elle est rassemblé et ça c'est
extrêmement
car il flotte dans l'air comme un
étrange parfum d'ivresse immense bonheur
collectif et spontané qui ne comble pas
uniquement les supporters de la première
heure la demi finale france croatie par
exemple a fait vibrer plus de 20
millions de téléspectateurs parmi eux la
moitié pratiquement étaient des femmes
cette coupe du monde se savoure donc en
famille entre amis parmi une foule
d'inconnus autour d'un drapeau tricolore
devenu emblème de fierté étendard de
forme est là ils devraient le sentiment
d'appartenance et tous ensemble alors
qu'on a cherché à diviser
lescure certains jeux à pleurer de
bonheur
très bonne nouvelle politique la cote de
popularité du président de la république
et du premier ministre n'ont d'ailleurs
jamais été aussi élevée dans les
sondages faut plus l'arrêter et
reconnaissance voilà bien ce qu inspire
aussi l'équipe de france acclamé à son
retour mercredi soir à clairefontaine
des joueurs de football perçus comme des
symboles nationaux de vaillance et
d'enthousiasmant
c'est enthousiasme des supporteurs
notamment sur les champs elysées
mercredi soir semblé marquer une rupture
avec la retenue des spectateurs
installés au stade de france c'est du
moins le constat des tricolores et de
didier deschamps en tête qui demande
pour dimanche l'aide de tout le public
il faudra chanter et danser avec la
france comme savent le faire les
brésiliens laurent frédéric bollée
les bonnes intentions étaient pourtant
là mais mercredi soir le public n'a
peut-être pas été à la hauteur de
l'équipe de france
en entrant sur la pelouse de saint denis
les joueurs ont paraît-il était choqué
de l'entendre qu'une maigre clameur au
lieu d'une ferveur totale et désiré
c'est vrai que le public français est
traditionnellement exigent parfois
davantage spectateurs que supporters et
si certains s'habillent en bleu ça n'est
pas encore un réflexe généralisée autre
problème du stade de france le nombre
important d'invités forcément plus
tièdes combiné au prix élevé des places
cela donne une ambiance plus molle que
les joueurs ne l'avaient espéré
ils ont donc décidé de vire et tant pis
pour les porteurs de costume cravate
je dis bravo à tous les français mais
bien ce que je leur demanderais aussi
c'est que lors des matches qui sont dans
les tribunes ce qui laisse tomber les
les cravates qui se mettent à une paire
de baskets et qui se met un peu de boue
sur le stade parce que on a besoin d'eux
aussi quoi
en clair et à la différence d'autres
nations comme le brésil où elle est au
stade représente une fête visuelle
sonore est permanente
il n'y aurait pas toujours communion
entre l'équipe de france et son public
dans ce mondial les joueurs le
regrettent donc avant la finale il
espère bien sûr un supplément de soutien
qu'on assimile souvent un douzième homme
sur le terrain car ce qui est sûr c'est
que le public de l'équipe de france
existent et couteau après les matchs que
peut-être pendant à clairefontaine la
curiosité et la dévotion des supporteurs
qui se massent devant l'entrée du
château où l'équipe de france
aujourd'hui se prépare loin des caméras
une journée à huis clos qui ne décourage
pas la ferveur des amateurs comme des
touristes viennent la voir andré germain
sur aucun guide touristique vous ne
verrez conseiller un détour par ce petit
bout de route des yvelines pourtant sur
les hauteurs de kerfontaine à la grille
du centre technique national de football
se succèdent depuis dix jours des
centaines de curieux ou de supporters
ils viennent en balade ou en
reconnaissance avec l'espoir de croiser
par un heureux hasard un joueur de
l'équipe de france
et parfois c'est carrément la tante spa
de trois heures on attend souvent pour
rien mais parfois la patience est
récompensée
j'ai quand même à une chance pour les
filles surtout qu'ils font est pour moi
un peu plus bas le village de
clairefontaine semble vivre paisiblement
la coupe du monde il ya bien ce coq
devant la mairie qui laisse à penser
qu'ici on aime le sport mais on est
stupéfait de voir les jours de match
pierre fontaine se réveiller les 850
habitants montent en direction du
château saluer le départ des joueurs
vers le stade
aujourd'hui aux côtés des cléry font
cela il y avait quelques télés pour
faire tout terrain précis et pendant ce
temps au rosé touraine on se réjouit de
voir tant de monde venu de si loin
même si ici seuls les bleus sont des
princes et jacques est le roi la gazette
un homme charmant quand il passe il nous
dit toujours bonjour toujours
je prends il est très humain il est venu
nous apporter son milieu de numéro 23
mais pourquoi par sympathie je pense et
vous lui avez demandé non ils n'ont pas
aimé jacquet tient justement le voilà il
a pu mesurer l'engouement des supporters
qui n'auront pas attendu pour rien et
nous retrouvons maintenant à
clairefontaine ne vienne la voix quelles
informations ont filtré aujourd'hui
malgré ce huis clos
tout d'abord rien de très sportif ce
matin parce que les joueurs ont pu aller
par grappes partir en voiture jusqu'au
centre commercial voisin faire des
courses sur des petits achats surtout se
distraire par ce qu'ils aiment et
jacques et insister là dessus il faut
maintenant décompresser essayer de
récupérer un petit peu faire des soins
penser à autre chose et puis ensuite
seulement dans l'après midi ils se sont
remis à l'entraînement parce que vous
savez qu'un sportif de haut niveau a
besoin de s'entraîner pour ne pas perdre
ses acquis donc ils se sont entraînés
très légèrement guide pour ceux qui
avaient encore envie de faire quelques
efforts
certains vous le voyez lizarazu desailly
ou encore des chansons parti à
bicyclette faire un petit tour tout
simplement se balader pour en profiter
un petit peu à l'heure qu'il est et bien
les joueurs doivent maintenant être en
train de manger des dîners comme
beaucoup d'entre nous enfin d'autres en
tout cas et puis ensuite logiquement
aimé jacquet décortiquera un petit peu
les forces de l'équipe du brésil on les
connaît déjà un peu mais surtout ses
faiblesses il faut à décortiquer sa à
l'aide de la vidéo et puis ensuite on
leur souhaite un bon dodo
et puis nous on aura l'occasion de les
retrouver demain lors d'un point presse
aux alentours de midi merci yann lavoix
pendant ce temps là l'équipe brésilienne
à ozoir-la-ferrière entamé en public ces
dernières phases d'entraînement avec
cette incertitude autour de l'état de
santé de ronaldo toutes les rumeurs
circulent aujourd'hui florent gautreau
frédéric basket une crise à ozoir
ronaldo raconte ses déboires
sa cheville droite fait souffrir depuis
la demi-finale et dès le premier
exercice cet après-midi le mal lancinant
est revenu la décision de l'entraîneur
ne tarde pas
o mieres ronaldo va se contenter de
courir à l'écart avec un adjoint de
sagan et il n'y a pas de problème
d'alcool
on le ménage pour qu'il soit reposée
personne n'ose imaginer un forfait de
ronaldo ni non plus d'ailleurs qui
travaillent d'arrache-pied pour jouer
dimanche qu'il travaille même sa frappe
du pied gauche occasion en attendant les
supporters brésiliens ont profité du
dernier entraînement public pour
encourager leurs protégés
2000 spectateurs tout en jaune pour un
simple entraînement ça doit faire rêver
nos français en mal de soutien populaire
les brésiliens se sont entraînés une
heure et demie dans une ambiance très
détendue
le retour de leur arrière cafu rassure
le sélectionneur les champions du monde
en titre ne doute pas c'est certain
françois goulard première finale ils
seraient jamais intervenues à nous nous
avons l'habitude de ce genre d'événement
l'expérience un argument de poids pour
les brésiliens
ils sont prêts bien décidé à conquérir
leur cinquième couronne mondiale avec ou
sans ronaldo les brésiliens se voit
vainqueur il voit déjà dunga brandir la
coupe du monde il nous retrouvons
maintenant à ozoir-la-ferrière florent
gautreau que sait-on du programme à
venir de l'équipe brésilienne qui demain
s'entraînera à huis clos je crois savoir
que la pression monte pour la seleçao
ouais ouais la pression monter la
pression monte aussi chez les supporters
qui se retrouvent ici au sens de tabac
ya tous les soirs après l'entraînement
des brésiliens c'est une véritable fête
mais aussi même les supporters
commencent à être tendu vous l'avez dit
la pression monte chez les joueurs qui
eux
je vous rassure sont plus au calme dans
leur château hôtel à lésigny à deux
kilomètres d'ici ils s'entraîneront
effectivement à huit clos demain dans
l'enceinte même de leur hôtel pour ne
pas être dérangé même leurs proches
leurs compagnes n'auront pas le droit de
leur rendre visite d'ici à dimanche soir
vous le savez c'est un moment capital
peut-être pour la france mais aussi pour
le brésil qui espère conquérir son
cinquième titre mondial il ya 160
millions de sélectionneurs au brésil
c'est ce qu'on a coutume de dire eh bien
je peux vous dire qu'ici il ya des
milliers de supporters qui n'attendent
qu'une chose la victoire pour pouvoir
continuer à faire la fête tous les soirs
à ozoir vol à béatrice merci florent
gautreau dans le cadre de la coupe du
monde toujours près de 350 mille
personnes sont attendues autour du
champs de mars à paris pour assister
dans moins d'une heure à ce concert des
trois ténors josé carreiras placido
domingo luciano pavarotti un événement
retransmis en moins diot vision murmure
que la chanson sous les ponts de paris
seraient au programme des ténors qui
chanteront en six langues
ambiance sur place ce film et elle et
bernard enflait ils sont venus du monde
entier trois cent mille mélomanes
attendus d'ici ce soir sur la pelouse du
champ de mars pour savourer gratuitement
un répertoire de grands classiques airs
d'opéra bel canto ou simple chansonnette
d'or n'aurait fujita et c'est justement
lui que l'on vient à clamer aujourd'hui
luciano pavarotti et ses deux acolytes
placido domingo et josé carreiras pour
un concert à l'unisson trois ténors pour
une affiche qui vaut le détour pour nous
chanter à paris
cela va être une expérience
exceptionnelle un événement avant paris
les ténors ont déjà eu le temps de roder
la formule roman 90 los angeles quatre
ans plus tard toujours à l'occasion de
la coupe du monde de foot
c'est
à chaque fois la foule est au rendez
vous il ya chaque fois l'opération se
transforme en excellente affaire pour
les maisons de disque des trois stars
les cds de leurs précédents concerts se
sont vendus à des millions d'exemplaires
la sortie de l'enregistrement live du
concert de ce soir est prévue le 17 août
pas une minute de répit pour les sirènes
du marketing les puristes gras seront
sans doute des dents mais ce qui compte
finalement c'est que le livre
ce démocrate ce vendredi les départs en
vacances s'ajoute au départ pour ce long
week end férié la journée était classée
rouge en ile de france mais aux portes
de paris la circulation était plutôt
fluide demain bison futé prévoit une
journée rouge en province vous serez
donc nombreux à prendre la route dans
les heures qui viennent une nouvelle
fois la sécurité routière appelle à la
prudence les automobilistes d'autant que
le bilan d'avril sur les routes
françaises est marqué par une forte
augmentation 630 personnes ont trouvé la
mort pour ce seul mois d'avril une
nouvelle campagne de prévention ces
jours ci incite les conducteurs à
s'arrêter fréquemment car selon une
étude scientifique sur un trajet de
quatre heures comme paris lyon
un automobiliste d'or au volant pendant
six minutes
alban nicosie en chine et fish et c'est
une expérience qui fait froid dans le
dos sur le parcours paris lyon 50
volontaires ont été équipés d'un
électroencéphalogramme pour étudier les
périodes de fatigue au volant
le résultat est édifiant chaque point
représente un instant de sommeil au
volant sur quatre heures de trajet ça
fait six minutes d'absence
et quand il n'ya plus personne au volant
la conduite devient dangereuse sur
autoroute lorsqu'on rentre on a une
impression de confort de sécurité
on roule je dirais entre guillemets
comme sur des rails et ce sentiment
insidieux propice à l'engourdissement
tue chaque année plus de 100 personnes
une campagne d'information vous incitera
donc cet été à marquer des pauses
régulières sur les aires aménagées sur
l'autoroute
instinctivement on essaye de résister
quand même un petit temps et
sur cette carte du cerveau on voit peu à
peu l'activité cérébrale passé du bleu
au rouge c'est à dire se ralentir après
1h30 de conduite
l'électroencéphalogramme confirme cette
lassitude
bien évidemment il s'agit là d'une
moyenne mais la prévention routière
conseille d'observer ce rythme de deux
heures de conduite une heure de repos
pour les départs en vacances depuis ce
matin dans la région d'aix-en-provence
les incendies qui ont ravagé près de 300
hectares de garrigue sont maîtrisés
reste que les pompiers les pilotes des
canadair sont sur le qui-vive jean
pierre chevènement visite officielle
dans les bouches du rhône annoncé un
nouveau plan de lutte contre les feux de
forêt cette année le ministre de
l'intérieur en a profité pour rencontrer
les pilotes de bombardier d'eau en grève
vincent nguyen dominique bonnet le plein
effet tout est prêt à la moindre alerte
ce canadair prendra l'air pour éteindre
au plus vite une forêt qui s'embrase et
pourtant son pilote est en grève comme
les autres cette drôle de grève où tout
le monde travaille dur depuis un mois
maintenant nous devrons le faire nous
sommes heures le soir contre 1 force et
nous le faisons quand même nous sommes
réquisitionnés pour effectuer notre
métier il refuse cependant d'être
détaché dans d'autres bases
parce qu'ils jugent leurs frais de
mission à suffisant l'autre
revendication porte sur les salaires
qu'ils aimeraient voir aligner sur ceux
des pilotes instructeurs du centre de
formation aéronautique
deux canadair en moyenne en est fait 21
mille francs et un pilote du cfaa il
fait comment
on verra 35000 a encore de 7000 en
moyenne une augmentation de 50% ce n'est
quand même pas banal
1 vous êtes bien conscient 1 c'est quand
même difficile quoi alors il faut
regarder où on en est exactement je
pense que il faut trouver une solution
qui soit réaliste
même s'il reste prudent jean pierre
chevènement s'est montré rassurant ce
matin déclarant qu'il interviendrait
auprès du ministre du budget voire même
de lionel jospin au revoir ça représente
une grosse somme
d'un seul coup mais si on avait fait le
travail comme ça avait été prévu il ya
dix ans on n'en serait pas là
quels problèmes sont d'ores et déjà
réglé aucun
tellement écrit par écrit aucun dès cet
après midi une délégation est allée
négocier à paris pendant ce temps les
traqueurs se relayer pour surveiller la
forêt méditerranéenne vigilant les
pilotes le sont dans leur métier comme
dans la cave
les prix à la consommation selon l'
indice provisoire de l'insee une infime
l'augmentation entre 0 et 0,1 pour cent
en juin
sur les 12 derniers mois les prix ont
augmenté de 1%
leur père a adopté aujourd'hui les
nouveaux statuts de l'alliance devant le
comité politique philippe séguin a lui
aussi frappé par les vertus de la
victoire des tricolores
après l'image de l'équipe de france pour
exalter la nation et utiliser le symbole
du sport pour répondre au premier
ministre carole comment christian hutin
le rpr vite une première la mise en
place d'une toute nouvelle instance
composée de délégués non plus nommé par
la direction mais élu par les
fédérations avec la première réunion de
son comité politique le mouvement
gaulliste poursuit sa remise en marche
alors que la cohabitation est en vedette
dans les sondages
actuellement les français suivent la
coupe du monde sont bonne humeur tout se
passe bien donc c'est la raison
principale j'essaie de prendre du monde
qu'il faut pas amalgamer les scores
croissant de jeux ce pas la réalité sur
l'action gouvernementale
la coupe du monde qui a aussi envahi le
terrain politique et permis à philippe
séguin d'ironiser sur les propos tenus
récemment par le premier ministre se
chausse pas le même qui nous a expliqué
qu'il ait fait la moitié de jacques et
la moitié des zidane je pense qu'il ne
nous en voudra pas tout cas je l'espère
de nous réjouir et pour jacquet et pour
zidane et pour l'efficacité de l'équipe
de france qui dirait quand même aussi
les deux autres boîtiers des piques
contre le gouvernement mais surtout la
perspective de ce débat sur l'europe
prévues à l'automne au sein du mouvement
gaulliste un débat pour tenter enfin de
mettre un terme aux divisions internes
le rpr n'est pas encore en vacances
qu'ils préparent déjà activement sa
rentrée
l'archevêque d'aix-en-provence
louis-marie billets a été nommé
aujourd'hui par jean paul ii archevêque
de lyon et primat des gaules et il
succède à monseigneur jean balan décédé
en mars dernier à versailles le comité
central d'entreprise de giat industries
a été marquée par un rejet unanime du
plan social qui devrait toucher quelques
trois mille 600 suppressions d'emplois
plusieurs manifestations avaient karen
250 salariés qui ont occupé le hall de
la mairie de rennes
près d'un millier d'autres manifester à
tarbes à toulouse
un mouvement qui d'après les syndicats
devraient se poursuivre à la rentrée
et puis la fin de la grève des
animateurs en costume à disneyland un
mouvement commencé il y a tout juste
trois semaines en irlande du nord
nouvelle nuit de tension alors que des
milliers de protestants se disent
toujours déterminé à traverser les
quartiers catholiques de la ville
le premier ministre britannique tony
blair lance un appel au calme affirmant
qu'il ne laissera pas le processus de
paix devenir l'otage des extrémistes
eric mené toute la journée
le face à face s'est prolongée police et
armée britannique d'un côté et là au
delà des barbelés
une poignée de manifestants protestant
irréductibles un face-à-face crispés
moins violente cependant que la nuit
dernier une cinquième nuit de
protestations qui a tourné à
l'affrontement cloud cocktails molotov
contre gaz lacrymogènes
cinq policiers blessés
les militants de l'ordre d'orange ne
digère toujours pas l'interdiction qui
leur est faite de parader à travers le
quartier catholique de portadown une
tradition pour commémorer la victoire de
guillaume d'orange sur les catholiques
en 16190 tony blair le premier ministre
britannique s'y oppose toujours au nom
des progrès dans le processus de paix en
irlande d'une une grosse différence
depuis cette année la grande majorité
des habitants d'irlande du nord veulent
que ce processus de paix continuent ils
ont voté pour cela dans un référendum et
de manière écrasante
ils ont voté pour ceux qui défendent ce
processus dans une élection à
l'assemblée et de manière écrasante
ils l'ont fait parce qu'ils veulent que
la loi du royaume uni soit appliquée les
forces de l'ordre ont reçu de nouveaux
renforts à porter d'armes le week-end
qui commence est à haut risque
et tout à l'heure les protestants
enregistrait accepter des négociations
indirectes avec les résidents catholique
du quartier de portadown précisément
peut-être un espoir de dénouer cette
crise à berlin ibères védrine le
ministre des affaires étrangères a posé
aujourd'hui la première pierre de la
future ambassade de france qui va être
reconstruite là même où elles se
trouvaient avant guerre avant d'être
détruite par les bombes et les tirs
d'artillerie en 1945
je vous propose maintenant de revivre
l'histoire de cette ambassade de france
édifié dans les années 1870 acheté par
napoléon iii et dont le destin se
confond avec l'histoire de l'allemagne
nazie comme guide
l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères jean françois poncet qui est
passé son enfance dans les couloirs de
cette ambassade que dirigeait son père
pendant la montée d'hitler
olivier lerner jean françois poncet a
grandi au numéro 5 pariser platz la
place de paris devant la porte de
brandebourg en 1931 son père est
ambassadeur de france en allemagne
le to berlin fréquente les salons de ce
petit versailles au balcon on voit tout
on comprend tout la menace qui montrent
la guerre qui arrive le vacarme du
troisième reich
jean françois poncet l'a vécue avec ces
yeux d'enfants qui n'ont jamais oublier
l' incendie du reichstag en 1933 de sa
chambre qui n'existe plus il a tout vu
tout entendu
j'avais ça quand j'étais en train de me
mettre au lit quand la personne qui me
mettait au lit et qui a regardé par la
fenêtre
akita coups sûrs les reichstadt brûlent
des riches cac brent
je me souviens de ça comme si c'était
hier et je me souviens d'être sorti de
mon lit et d'avoir regardé le ciel qui
rougeoie y est puisque comme vous le
voyez le reich tag est tout à fait à
côté et jouxte en réalité leur vsab le
baisemain des nazis pour sa mère
son père connaissait bien hitler je
crois qu il impressionnait un peu par
cette connaissance de l'allemagne de
l'allemagne historique que iter ne
possédait que très superficiellement
il mettait en garde hitler arrêté par
barbie en france déportés en autriche
andré françois poncet est revenu après
la guerre constater les dégâts ambassade
bombardées et détruites
la nouvelle ambassade de france ne
ressemblera pas à celle qui la connaît
mais classique mi moderne
il n'ya que l'adresse qui est restée la
même il faudra encore un peu de temps
pour que l'ambassadeur de france puis
s'asseoir dans son bureau comptait bien
trois ans pour la construction mais le
plus urgent c'est l'examen du terrain en
profondeur une pluie d'obus s'est
abattue sur berlin juste avant la fin de
la guerre et le territoire français sur
lequel nous nous trouvons n'a jamais été
sondé retour en france sur les lieux de
vacances près de monaco dans les eaux
internationales un pétrolier pour la
deuxième année consécutive s'est
installé pour vendre un carburant détaxé
aux plaisanciers
on imagine le succès de cette vente hors
taxe quand on sait qu'un plein de gros
bateaux peuvent valoir jusqu'à 120 mille
francs unis vétéran didier beaumont
ceci est une station de service flottant
en fait un petit pétrolier d'une
soixantaine de mètres de long et
contenant 180 mille litres de fuel le
spiro f est positionné à une soixantaine
de kilomètres de tous les grands ports
de plaisance de méditerranée de saint
tropez ou de monaco de cannes ou de san
remo
certains propriétaires de yachts
n'hésitent pas à venir s'y
approvisionner le spiro f est dans les
eaux internationales
il bat pavillon maltais et la société
qui l'exploitent soeurette italienne
quant aux carburants
il est vendu sans taxes et sa provenance
est un secret je ne sais pas c'est un
côté bancaire de produits pour les
douanes le spirou est fait un problème
car vendre du carburant aux zones
internationales n'est pas interdit mais
les plaisanciers qui en achètent eux
peuvent être en fraude
le manque à gagner pour l'état est
facile à calculer le spiro f20
ce que l'on sait litres de gasoil en
france si vous avez la pompe sur le
territoire national ou le payer quatre
fois environ ce qui fait manque à gagner
de 3 francs si on prend unité qui comme
celle là qui ravitaille à peu près 20 me
de litres ça fait un manque à gagner de
60 me de france pour les douanes
importés sont déclaration du carburant
est simplement de la contrebande un
délit passible d'une forte amende
l'année dernière une quarantaine de
plaisanciers a été verbalisé pour ans de
leur avocat pourtant rien d'illégal n'a
été commis dans le carburant peuvent
être assignées à des vivres et eau
nécessaire pour l'avitaillement d'un
bateau il n'y a pas d'article
spécifiques y dit le carburant doit être
déclaré comme produits importés
lorsqu'on arrive en france le tribunal
correctionnel de grasse décidera en
octobre prochain si oui ou non ce trafic
de carburant est légal le spiro f lui
passera l'été à attendre les yachtman
économe la fierté le sentiment national
après les stades du mondial la
préparation du traditionnel défilé du 14
juillet auquel assistaient frédéric
renaud hergé mathurin 5 heures du matin
le président de la république s'est fait
excuser le temps d'une répétition il
vous prête son command car sa voiture
spéciale 14 juillet vous voilà à sa
place au coeur de la parade
autour de vous les 270 cavaliers de la
garde républicaine les petits débutants
qui ont le trac et les vieux de la
vieille comme le front pète major c'est
un métier ça s'apprend mon premier 14
juillet je n'ai pas mal sur le bitume il
peut glisser donc là à part s'accrocher
il vaut mieux parce que le règlement est
clair interdit de tomber interdite faire
une fausse note
interdit de faire un faux pas et en plus
il faut faire un bon chrono
kadri des baïonnettes qui est formé par
le 1er régiment d'infanterie et une
présentation en ordre serré qui va durer
neuf minutes 37 soit 23 secondes de
moins que l'an dernier
ne leur dites pas que malgré tout ça ils
sont aussi élégant qu'un corps de
ballerine parce qu'ils ont vraiment des
baïonnettes de la rigueur encore de la
rigueur au concours de défilé il en
reste encore qui n'ont pas tout à fait
compris les règles du 14 juillet coup
d'envoi de mad la 85e édition du tour de
france pour la première fois le tour
partira d'irlande le prologue à dublin
puis deux étapes dimanche et lundi aux
couleurs de la france l'irlande se
prépare un événement sportif
considérable que l'on est prêt à fêter
dignement sur place etienne leenhardt
pendant que les coureurs du tour de
france entraîné ce matin à la conduite à
gauche l'irlande terminer les
préparatifs en signe de bienvenue une
palissade tricolore que ces ouvriers ont
pris le temps de peindre à quelques
heures du départ de la course
on espère qu'ils l'aveyron mais il faut
quand même qu'il fasse gaffe de regarder
la route depuis ce matin tous les
villages que traversera le tour wirth
aubeleau blanche bleu blanc rouge chez
le pharmacien bleu blanc rouge chez le
tailleur qui pour faire plus français a
ajouté en vitrine baguette de pain
bouteille et gousses d'ail bleu blanc
rouge et panneaux indicateurs enfin chez
la fleuriste ravis d'accueillir le tour
de france j'ai mis les décorations parce
qu'on est très excité que le tour de
france passe chez nous et ça donne un
petit côté français à notre village
c'est qu'au delà de la simple curiosité
l'irlande est un pays où le vélo est une
seconde religion ce matin les
organisateurs du tour de france ont
déposé une gerbe sur la tombe du premier
cycliste irlandais à avoir porté le
maillot jaune en 1963 et un prêtre a
béni d'édition 98 nous prions pour tous
coureurs organisateurs pour leur
sécurité et pour une météo agréable sans
doute mesurera ton mieux la portée de
l'événement en écoutant ces cyclistes
amateurs venus se jauger sur le parcours
le tour chez eux ils l'avaient rêvé les
français l'ont fait vraiment un grand
honneur que l'on nous fait c'est quand
même la plus grande course cycliste au
monde qui partira d'irlande la honte
c'est qu'il n'y a aucun pouvoir
irlandais cette année mais bon peut-être
dans quelques années
moi en tout cas je suis déjà trop gros
demain tous seront sur le bord de la
route pour applaudir leur idole grâce au
passage du tour de france et aux
vocations qui pourrait susciter
l'avenir dira si après stephen roche en
1987 un autre irlandais est capable à
son tour de terminer en jaune sur les
champs elysées le tour de france c'est
aussi une immense logistique 24 heures
avant le prologue tout se met en place
aujourd'hui visite médicale pour les
coureurs alexandre kara nathalie gallet
pour le tour de france vire landes c'est
un peu la vie de château c'est dans le
quartier historique au coeur de dublin
que l'organisation s'est installée
ultimes préparatifs à la veille du
prologue qui ouvrira la ballade
irlandaise du tour un contre la montre
dans les rues de la capitale à quelques
heures du début de la course la première
étape pour les coureurs c'est la visite
médicale l'occasion de vérifier que tout
va bien et même de faire la conversation
cet accueil médical c'est plus
l'occasion d'une prise de contact
personnalisée avec les coureurs
on les voit tous un par un on peut
parler avec eux on parle avec leur
médecin avec leurs directeurs sportifs
deuxième étape le trombinoscope du tour
même pour les habitués l'exercice n'est
pas toujours évident je suis marié dans
les couloirs on croise le patron du tour
mais aussi des visages connus comme
celui de bernard hinault et déjà on
compare les millésimes
on a dit que l'autre france était facile
cette année il est tout simplement un
tout petit peu moins exigeant que
l'année dernière sur le plan de la
montagne jusqu'à l'an dernier il avait
25 grands cols escaladés nain aura 23
cette année
quand les champions font des pronostics
les journalistes écoute et prennent des
notes
favorite
après place pour dire fin d'année
risquent demain
pas de circulation dans la vieille ville
de dublin les coureurs s'élanceront sans
pour autant être obligé de rouler à
gauche hormis quelques détails tout est
prêt pour l'entrée en scène de la grande
boucle
l'événement à aix en provence avec le
don giovanni de mozart revisité par le
metteur en scène peter brook qui marque
ainsi son retour à l'opéra
un spectacle moderne joyeux talentueux
et inattendue les puristes ne s'y
retrouve pas forcément georges de bégoux
michel levasseur
e
on s'amuse beaucoup dans la mise en
scène dépouillée à l'extrême de peter
brook
il a choisi la comédie plutôt que donne
après tout il y a là une jolie bande de
jeunes gens qui se divertissent même si
l'un d'entre eux dans le dur banny a
fait de la séduction et du danger qu'une
règle de vie qui le conduit vers la mort
les avocats pourront assister là dessus
que selon ce que l'on vous le présente
en fait c'est un jeu c'est nous mêmes
mais ce n'est pas je veux dire une
situation vraiment réel mais on va le
présenter avec les émotions telles qu'on
lire sans et puis peut-être qu'on va
plus savoir exactement où cette
frontière entre la réalité et le jeu
non
m
aujourd'hui on joue beaucoup plus
légèrement du monarque lui disant votre
maîtrise des vêtements qui correspondent
plutôt au personnage d'une manière très
simple et direct et tout ce qui compte
c'est ce qu'exprime la personne à
recherche dans mozart c'est quelque
chose qui parce qu'à travers la musique
et c'est toujours des sentiments humains
qui s'exprime c'est ça qui manque
c'est sous le signe de la liberté
revendiquée par don giovanni que le
festival d'aix fête ses 50 ans et veut
retrouver une nouvelle jeunesse
et bah
festival toujours mais celui ci
s'intéresse au jazz c'est à montreux
avec ce jeune groupe anglais morty bas
qui mélange un pop music doux avec un
jazz plutôt sensuelle olivier les
nougats à christophe génial
un voyage musical sur les bords du lac
léman en compagnie du groupe londonien
morte chiba un gros futé ainsi chaque
point deux frères qui se sont acoquinés
il ya quatre ans à une boule de candeur
skye edwards une union à 3 fondée sur un
principe essentiel
l'honnêteté c'est très important que les
musiciens jouent ce qu'ils ressentent
majeur le plaisir la joie
si les gens qui viennent à nos concerts
sont émus alors j'estime qu'on a fait
notre travail
sky et ses acolytes multiplie
actuellement les voyages à travers
l'europe après belfort et son festival
de rock menti mais est allé jazz et à
montreux promouvoir la sortie de son
second album
mme chiba un groupe nourrit de folk de
blues de soul et de reggae le melting
pop réussie de 3 musiciens qui ont fait
souffler à montreux une tempête de
douceur retour sur les plages pour les
maillots de bain comme pour les cerises
il y à une saison avec gourmandise
jean-jacques du forez blesse grenier ont
croqué les nouveautés de la saison
vite installé à trois jours
attention ça va chauffer peut-être un
peu moins qu'en 1946 lorsqu'un ingénieur
français inventé le bikini tu mets quand
même le maillot c'est toujours un sujet
chaud
mais comment
les meilleures bases dominum primero
enfin sans soutien ça me gêne pas
l'esprit quoi qu'il en soit on peut en
voir de toutes les formes et de toutes
les couleurs à ce propos côté tendance
les maillots deviennent de plus en plus
technique grâce aux licra ils sont
maintenant résistant aux plans non
irritant et non transpirant et oui
parfois la science se met au service de
l'homme
souvent des filles est comme ça sur la
plage tous les jours et est à deux
heures quand les gens sont sont prêts à
nous accorder un petit peu de vent
attention pas qu'à des nouveaux maillots
très léger qui sèche très vite sur les
maillots plumes
j'en ai pas je resterai au passage
stratégique maillot plumes mais aussi
maillot mince si j'en crois les
magazines féminins on peut gagner 4 cm
de tour de taille sans régime à base de
litres à soft il offre dit-on indiscrets
maintien sinon la piaget par denis vous
y croyez vous au maillot minceur non
c'est marqué dans le journal
non je crois pas ce steve eastin région
cela dit faites moi quand même confiance
pour les hommes ce qui plaît le plus
c'est le boxer short
évidemment c'est pas sexy
non j'aime pas bien ce jeu mieux cacher
puis deviner uni ou imprimé le boxer
c'est le produit phare certains home and
away et d'écoulement pour éviter le
célèbre effet montgolfière 1 2 3 elle
tremblait de montrer quoi vivre bikini
au maillot de transe bronze ans il était
coulé 52 ans 52 ans d'innovation
exceptionnel et dire que certains n'ont
même pas conscience
ainsi se termine cette édition je vous
rappelle les principaux titres
aujourd'hui les départs en vacances
s'ajouter aux départs pour ce long
week-end férié
la journée était classée rouge en ile de
france mais aux portes de paris la
circulation est plutôt fluide
demain des entités prévoit une journée
rouge en province coup d'envoi du tour
de france prologue de mme à dublin en
irlande les derniers préparatifs visite
médicale des coureurs
et puis dans moins d'une demi-heure sur
le champ de mars à paris plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes pour
assister à ce concert unique des trois
ténors pavarotti carreiras domingo
diffusé en mondiovision dans un instant
la météo patrice drevet pluie le poireau
et valérie maurice
je vous remercie de l'attention
excellente fin de soirée ce conte
c'est une